what's in the box man I'm Homer Simpson
I'm spark Simpson nice no there's you
almost said Marge yeah I left it to his
own devices and he was like em eyes
bright or Sun he chose Sun this is the
show where we don't talk about our
relationship we talk about this
relationship the relationship we have
with what's in the box ladies and
gentlemen I live in hope that will open
this box and see something amazing
that's what the show spouts about hope
the new hope then Oh what up deep deep
cuts okay it's just taped up pretty well
here commentary from an expert man he's
ready for Mallrats - all right dig in
clear the peanuts the green pulp
testicles and let's find out Christmas
all right folks this is lego dimensions
for Xbox one this is the crossing of all
the University this is the multiverse of
Lego Summa [ __ ] was just like why are
we keeping them all sub you gotta keep
up separated he's like we gotta put them
all that we gotta put him up yeah and
it's Lego dimensions 14 initial
franchises have been included this is a
game I dreamed about when I was a kid we
had pitfall and hero like right on one
man one mission that never ended and
[ __ ] it was like those Lord of the Rings
movies this though is like taking
pitfall and then suddenly as you jump
over something
pac-man comes out you're like what and
then Donkey Kong just punch in the hole
yeah it's like it crosses the streams in
such a good way will cross the streams
excuse me gun you said crossing the
streams was bad listen to all the
franchises ready yes back to the future
yeah portal 2 what's portal 2 that's a
video game and there's a little like egg
peace thing robot look at how helpful
you could be about the modern things
like I got the old things covered like
long coal Jack you know I know what that
is and you're like that or ski nod yes
I've got very old references yours Berg
Kurt Simpsons Doctor Who
Ghostbusters Oh
the Midway arcade game Jurassic world
holy [ __ ] scooby-doo
Ninjago Unchained DC Comics Lord of the
Ring TCG I'm there right there for that
alone Lord of the Rings Wizard of Oz the
lego movie it was [ __ ] tremendous and
ghostbusters I think we already said but
it's so amazing my son we're saying it's
wise Will Arnett playing the Batman I'm
Batman
that's your boyfriend Elizabeth Banks
you know I know her Alison Brie she was
also in the lego movie yeah Peter
Capaldi that's Doctor Who the current up
to who yes
dan Castellaneta that's Homer Simpson
Michael J Fox Michael J Fox is a voice
in this game are you telling me you
built a time machine but this one has
toys that you stick toys on it yes pop
it open dude toys with a game oh do I
got a sock to make does that you don't
have you just have to open you get to
play with toys look at this all those
brand names each one of them with a TM
or are next to it do it comes with a
poster you boy you're simple dude it's
like they give you a game with toys
things crossed all the streams and
you're like it comes with the whoops and
it's the Lego piece we get to build
stuff like play it's gonna require
dexterity and creativity I thought we
were playing a video game I skip shop in
high school just taking all the fun
here's a good little quiz do you think
that's Batman's face or Gandalf sir
that's Gandalf and or Batman they could
both be ben affleck batman because those
are his two expressions
feel this oh you know I'm saying ribbed
for his pleasure that's what I think of
when I think of Lego
you're almost there dude no instructions
either bro this is nice it's like
watching like a Swiss watchmaker cuz
you're like the Ray of this [ __ ] you
just know how to do it man all right so
now we've got our figures together look
at that
fast for this bornus [ __ ] fast forward
man bad times up dude and I beat you by
building all of this myself look at you
what a poor showing that no I didn't
even look at this
studly to say the least okay so the idea
here is you build this base this your
dimensions portal you got all these
characters we're ready to go with the
game man oh please place a character on
the toy pet alright wait hold on don't
don't just pick random okay okay Batman
oh snap son there you go this is [ __ ]
this is now it's fun yes this little -
think I've ever seen can I place another
character the Batmobile
well that me are you that's you I'm
Batman you are Batman buy this all right
so wait but let's see who else we could
put on so if you add this is k9 from
Doctor Who
okay the fact that we live in a world
where there like not only there's their
canine Lego figure but he's in the game
let's see what happens oh my god my
[ __ ] pre-adolescent self just calmed
alright let's bring in the world that
don't want him Underwood oh look he says
I'm going up to grey let's see if Homer
is Homer it should be dan Castellaneta
today is the day for Homer chance baby
look at I'm ridin k9 a Batman riding k -
this is what I used to jerk off thinking
about this is crazy
mysterious voyage of Homer I'm
continuing the story
and all the characters are going into
the portal alright man
[Applause]
[Music]
come on oh my lord man that's everything
let's break more glass with our burps
look at that man rendered ineffective
man go I'm over yet baby
you're older I'm non canine oh man I
love the world of corporate synergy
let's roll
oh my god let's drive around Springfield
we can't drive around Springfield they
won't let us off the lawn do we have to
go off here
oh man take off and build this or maybe
we if we took a hoverboard dude get up
there that ain't gonna help me get up
there I need a net we need someone with
two jumping ability right so let's try
wild stuff she was in the movie this is
Elizabeth Banks
oh hello Kevin my career is way bigger
than yours now oh there she goes she got
some high flip peanuts right oh hello
birdie bird oh yeah boy this is pretty
fantastic all right look at me I'm on
canine if I try to jump off the roof
it's not what I mean
oh that's what they do in the movie oh
[Music]
it's a Jack's we could jack up the
garage and shot
there we go baby now what boo this
little thing I got put Homer there we
gotta go be Oh Homer you're right
bring them what happens there we go we
did it do it build right into to it sag
look at our programmers man I feel like
Mark Zuckerberg all right oh did you see
the board the fake plant Marge in the
garage that was pretty amazing come back
come back I'm not much of a gamer but I
could get along with this because this
is a fun I don't care about what the
mission is but like bullshitter don't
want me oh my god I killed myself that
man could never die especially Batman on
a hoverboard and we didn't even go to
middle-earth yet now let's check out
middle-earth where we going boss
I like extermination of Earth we got to
take that man that's alright take Batman
and let's try take shag shaggy all right
looks like we're going to the Daleks
kids experiment I see this finally
somewheres difference in Springfield oh
wow there's Millennium Falcon's bro no
that's from Doctor Who
hey there's the TARDIS
same old same old just the doctor and
Clara Oswald in the TARDIS oh this game
is emotional highs and lows cuz this
when you're like I hate it you like
that's the greatest thing that ever
happened every once in a while something
amazing happens like right now Marty
McFly is fighting Daleks and whooping
his ass who me applause over again smoke
we gotta turn the power off we gotta
turn the power yeah he must have called
me a chicken that's the only way to
outrage Marty McFly don't unless you
shoot him in the back quit it me I
didn't mean it shoot you in the back did
ya look at this [ __ ] and I like that you
could break [ __ ] that's always fun
[Music]
sometimes you just gotta raise like
Michael J Fox hotter than punching holes
in your sheetrock right yeah you ain't
kiddin dude BAM alright so get this man
we're diving into hill valley it took us
about as long to get tail valleys took
Marty in those movies in real time oh
look at that
and just when you thought you were gonna
play a video game it's another movie I
skipped it dude I learned how to skip it
alright
faith goobie I'm totally bringing this
too from Jurassic Park it looks like a
Velociraptor Tator
oh he is fast there you jump like a
psalm veg yeah I'm gonna be the guy from
Jurassic Park with the mint with the
pokey stick cop UB Scooby let's just
fight each other come here dog I'm
putting a hurt on that dog come here hot
dog yeah
[Music]
oh it came from the back snack attack
you with the guitar haha pop Aizen but
baizen looking at a Power Move yes oh
yes this is the greatest game ever man
if he could put scrappy tool in it and
cut his head off like all right so just
like in all your favourite movies you
could take all the characters that you
love make them fight each other yes so
there it is man we played as much as we
could and as we found out in the modern
day gaming is not fun whatsoever that
was a lot of work they were hot sorry
bye bye you like the moments I loved one
here too people's voices and stuff but
let's just watch the movies and stuff
like I agreed the movies can be too long
and if you but usually you can close out
of those first you have to put these
things together like a video game should
be mindless fun my mother should be able
to play a video game
could you imagine I'm like mom go to
hell Valley should be like her heart
would explode you don't know what I'm
talking about
there were sheer moments of absolute
bliss Batman on k-9 Batman on the
hoverboard yeah we'll always remember
thumbs up I guess you thumbs up for me
man that's all the time we got for this
week man that we found out what's in a
box you want to see us find out what's
in the box next week week after that
write to us and tell us what you wanted
to see in the box please not as complex
as this I shouldn't work this hard since
I was a busboy at Long John Silver's
that's it for this week mount Kevin
Smith Jim you thanks for hanging out
with us and finding out what was in the
box
[Music]
you